on va enchaîner Catherine avec de la
course d'orientation à quelques semaines
ça démarre le 29 juin c'est les
championnats du monde junior de course
d'orientation en République tchèque
c'est une course un peu méconnue du
grand public mais c'est une compétition
pour laquelle c'est qualifié un 50e noir
il s'appelle Quentin roturier à 17 ans
ce jeune ce jeune orienteur va
participer à ses premiers mondiaux alors
qu'il ne côtoie le haut niveau que
depuis seulement trois ans comment en
est-il arrivé là réponse avec Sophie Val
et le dis-moi
à peine savait-il lire que Quentin
roturier suivait les traces de ses
frères dans les courses d'orientation à
travers bois sur les collines ou dans
les chemins le saint cantinois semble
dans son élément comme s'il en
connaissait chaque recoin ça arrive
régulièrement et même maintenant et ça
ça arrive moins souvent maintenant mais
c'est toujours assez frustrant en fait
de se retrouver quelque part et de plus
avoir du tout on est donc en fait faut
arriver à prendre chaque élément du
terrain une colline un trou un chemin
pour pour le replacer sur la carte et
savoir exactement où on est à tout
moment et on a aussi la boussole qui
aide pas mal qui est pas mal dans ces
dans ces cas de figure
Quentin ne s'entraîne sérieusement que
depuis l'âge de 14 ans par dose d'une
session physique et de techniques
d'orientation par semaine et dès sa
première saison il intègre le groupe
France moins de 18 ans à 17 ans il
totalise déjà 12 podiums nationaux et 6
titres de champion de France mais le
dernier reste le plus marquant pour
quelques secondes il devance son grand
frère Maxime moi ma plus grande fierté
c'est vrai c'est de les voir après la
course tous les deux courir ensemble
récupérer et analyser leurs courses et
comparer pourquoi la NT devant et
pourquoi l'autre était derrière sans
aucune rivalité après deux championnats
d'Europe le 50e saisie sa chance lors du
dernier rassemblement de l'équipe de
France en vue des Mondiaux il y a
quelques semaines c'est un partenaire
d'entraînement qui lui apprend sa
sélection par SMS c'est de la joie
vraiment beaucoup de joie parce que
c'est c'est une préparation longue en
fait parce que de entre fin octobre et
début avril on a aucune course on a que
que des entraînements on n'a aucune
course nationale donc on a des weekends
où on se retrouve tous ensemble on voit
un peu mais pas forcément dans la même
condition qu'une compétition et on
déboule un peu sur les sélections sans
savoir trop où on en est et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un soulagement
de savoir que cet état là de la saison
est passée et qu'on peut vraiment se
concentrer maintenant sur les
champignons modèle de précocité pour ses
premiers mondes quant à roturier se
frottera des athlètes de 2 ans ces aînés
il visera alors un top 30 sur les profs
de sprint élève de première scientifique
il doit d'abord passer ses épreuves
anticipées du baccalauréat juste avant
de partir pour la République tchèque fin
juin
en baseball ce week-end la neuvième
journée de Division 2 avait lieu les
Cougars de Montigny recevaient les
Panthères de Pessac au complexe sportif
Jean maréchal les joueurs d'Arnaud faux
se sont facilement apposés 15-4 le matin
puis 13-3 dans le deuxième match de quoi
se mettre en confiance à une journée de
la fin de la saison régulière et d'aller
à la proche des playoffs du football oui
le club de football de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux accueillait ce
weekend la 16e édition de son
traditionnel tournoi international jeune
au total plus de 480 enfants originaires
notamment de la réunion de la Pologne se
sont affrontés une compétition réservée
aux jeunes de 12 et 13 ans chez lui 12
Rueil-Malmaison s'est imposé et chez
Louis XII et bah bien voisin de
Bretonneux a remporté le titre à
domicile voilà cocorico et quelques
infos sport pour continuer en athlétisme
nouveau meeting régional il y a quelques
jours pour les athlètes cadets et les
juniors une trentaine d'athlètes ivinois
s'était donné rendez-vous à théverny sur
100 mètres le jeûne espoir de l'Entente
Athlétique de 50 ans en Yvelines babacar
Diop que vous voyez à l'image c'est
imposé en 10 secondes 82 a priori une
performance ce qui pourrait paraître
tout à fait classique je pense que
lorsque l'on compare les performances de
l'élève de Philippe Lefebvre à celle de
Christophe Lemaitre le champion de
France du 100 mètres au même âge et bien
le 5 continents est plus rapide
Christophe Lemaitre courait alors en 10
secondes 96 centièmes de bonne guerre
pour la suite c'est clair ça fait
défense self-défense Catherine à partir
de septembre prochain un club de
self-défense et de kick-boxing va ouvrir
ses portes à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
dès janvier 2014 l'association profitera
des espaces du vélodrome de 50 ans en
Yvelines renseignement à l'adresse mail
qui s'affiche sur votre écran voilà
cette force est fini pour ce lundi merci
Anthony merci à vous n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à commenter sur cette suite
sport sur Twitter avec le hashtag tout
attaché le 7 8 sport bonne soirée à
lundi prochain